this is a food bank in the West Midlands
where the vast majority of recipients
are Asylum Seekers It's set up to
support people whilst they wait for
their claims to be processed
for some that can mean years trapped in
a buckling system unable to officially
work or move on with their lives
[Music]
as we film watch the face of the man on
the left Joy from 18 year old hossam
buffer as a translator explains he fits
the cohort of people whose applications
will now be fast-tracked
is from Syria and arrived in July 2021
so you've actually just broken the news
to this man yeah and it actually I've
just seen his face change he's smiling
now
he's here her dream he can live in this
country in peace
for the list of five countries has left
others like baramajara and his
seven-year-old son bitterly disappointed
they are from Iran which has seen major
anti-government protests
I skipped from there because of my
religion I'm Christian
so they don't like me or they there is
not really a freedom of religion or
that's why I left Iran
it means the fear of a separate home
office Asylum strategy
Iraqi kurd Kamal Hassan says his son
lives in fear of his parents being sent
to Rwanda same Iraq and Afghanistan same
same my
my my government is no good
those who are eligible for the new
policy will have to fill out a 10-page
questionnaire rather than an in-person
interview if people don't have the right
help to fill in the forms there will be
a slight concern that that might
Prejudice the outcome
um but you know overall if there's a
fast tracking system you know that is to
be welcomed the Prime Minister has
pledged to cut the backlog of Asylum
Seekers but new figures show nearly 161
000 claims are still awaiting processing
a record number by fast-tracking
individuals from these countries you're
effectively putting a green light up so
it makes it much more
um welcoming for people to make that
long trip to the UK in the hope of
gaining Asylum
critics described the announcement as an
amnesty in all but name others say it
speeds up claims which would almost
certainly be approved Mr Holland Skyrims